Jen I know you have a very busy schedule
you're traveling you're teaching an
upcoming workshop yeah you mentioned it
yes I'm teaching in New York on August
12th and 13th with screenwriters world
and that's mastering the TV pilot and
then I am teaching in London
Labor Day weekend for us that is the
London screenwriting festival and I'm
doing a masterclass the day before the
festival I'm writing a TV pilot that
sells and then I'm teaching three
classes at the festival that go bit
really all three go into one is finding
your voice the other is the internal
story elevating emotion and then the
last is why the audience returns having
to do with the internal story
interesting I'm fascinated by all of
them but especially the last one so why
the audience returns does that mean a
series yeah of writing let Steven take
like a Harry Potter or something like
that or you know better call Saul which
is a spin-off of you know Breaking Bad
so what is it do you feel that is why
the audience returns I think the biggest
why ironically is the setting up of the
why why the character wants what they
want and this is the internal story like
when I look at series that should have
gone because they had all the components
they had the huge executive producers
they had the right network they had the
right actors and the story failed and
the reason that I have found on shows
that haven't worked it's the failure to
develop the internal story and the
season one arc of the series and that
has to do with the development of the
why of the central
character because if we don't understand
why the character wants what they want
we don't have a rooting interest and we
don't know why we're coming back and you
can look at shows like if I were to
think about all of the television shows
that are working and this could go into
features too and but of the TV shows
that are currently working when you look
at blind spot and you look at the Good
Wife and you look at homeland and you
look at the blacklist and you look at
night manager and you go why is the
audience returning and you know a show
like The Good Wife you're going to say
we're not returning to watch the law
case each week the reason why we're
returning is because Peter committed a
sex scandal scandal that landed him in
jail and created the dilemma for Alicia
of having to bring security back to her
family
leading Alicia to return to a law career
that she abandoned 13 years before
adding the complication that her college
sweetheart will hires her so that
triangle in the setup of that triangle
on an emotional level is what brings the
audience back will Alicia stay loyal to
Peter who betrayed her and not give in
to her connection with will who rescued
her and who she has a history with and
that question is really what brings us
back when you look at homeland you think
Kerry you think will Caray remain loyal
to the mission or will she give in to
the fact that she feels love for Brody
who she is meant
bring down that brings us back that
makes us because it's not a one and out
it's an ongoing dilemma that we can't
wait anticipation wise to see what
happens and and that again comes down to
to the powerful question that comes out
of the series trigger and dilemma you
know in the case of homeland which I
think has one of the strongest season
art questions
is Brody the prisoner of war that turned
or not and that's how you set up a
concept that leads the audience to want
to return because they have a very big
at night manager certainly you know
there was incredibly powerful moment of
loss that we wanted to understand was
the character after that loss still
going to be able to get what they wanted
you